Dams.
All right.
So I'm going to finish talking
about overlapping generations today.
I'm going to defer my plan to save
social security till a couple of lectures
from now. And I'm going to start to
introduce uncertainty in this class.
The exam will only cover the stuff
up to basically the last problem set.
So you can, um, uh,
there are a few things about overlapping
generations I might say today,
which we'll clarify what you already know,
but you don't have to know anything beyond
the problem you turned in on Thursday
on a, you're turning in today. So,
so you I think are better informed
now than you were yesterday.
I think it's a big help
to be doing the problems.
So for those of you watching on screen
at home, you know, do the problems.
So the, uh, the,
remember we had a situation where
there were, there were generations,
each of whom was rich when young and poor,
when old that looked like that.
And uh,
and it went on forever.
That was the only difference
from what we've had before.
People's lives were shorter than the
lifetime of the economy. And to be,
to go to the extreme,
the economy goes on forever,
even though where people only live a two
periods. And then there was land, one,
one, one, one. So here's land, here's,
uh, and then there's
generous. Sorry. There's land.
And then there's generation as I forgot
the generation. Here's generation,
zero generation,
one generation to generation three.
Dot, dot, dot, and time. This is time.
And here's time, one time, two
time, three time, four time,
five, et cetera. Now this model I've
been told is the hardest thing you do.
The entire class, things are going
to get much more complicated.
But since they build up slowly,
I think this model is the hardest thing
that you have to do. The entire class.
I realize it's a little bit confusing,
but in the end,
I don't think it's that
complicated. And it, it, it,
it reveals all of a subtlety
of fishers thinking,
not that Fisher understood about
overlapping generations, but the,
his ideas you can see here.
So what are his ideas?
You've got a complicated model in which
you've got people trading apples when
they're young, uh, against land. So the,
to the objects in the economy,
our land,
which are supposed to
think of the stock market.
Okay.
So we've got land and we've got um,
we've got land. Yes. And we've got apples.
So
now what's interesting is the land
is going to constantly change hands.
So the young here are going to buy
the land, but when they get old,
they're going to sell the land.
So the land is constantly changing hands.
It's not that one person buys it at
the beginning and holds it forever.
So fishers formula, remember,
was that the price of any asset,
what's it going to be equal
to the, uh, discounted,
discounted dividends.
And the logic seem to be
at the time that the price,
you know,
if the person was going to buy the asset,
they could take the money now or they
could wait and get all the dividends in
the future and they would compare,
you know,
what they would get out of the dividends
in the future to what they have to give
up today. But you see in this example,
it's a little more complicated.
Nobody's going to hold the land
till and get all the dividends.
Each person who buys the land knows that
he's going to sell it long before the
land of stock, you know, before, before
getting all the dividends from the land.
And yet the price of the land
is still given by this formula.
So we never used the fact in fishers
argument that the same person had to hold
the asset till the end.
And so now we have a case in extreme
case where people only hold the asset for
one period. It's always turning
over, turning over, turning over.
But still the price of the asset is
equal to the discounted dividends.
So the secret to solving this problem
according to Fisher is forget about the
acid that makes it too complicated.
Fisher's argument,
again is take financial equilibrium and
arch and write it on a different board
versus argument is financial equilibrium
equity Librium okay,
get rid of acids.
Put dividends into endowment,
okay.
Into an Downlands.
Okay.
And transform it into general,
like Librium the very thing you solved
in the first couple days of class. Okay.
And then go backwards and figured out
what the financial equilibrium is.
So although it seemed very easy before,
it's a little subtler this time,
but it's the same principle.
Who's endowment should you
put the dividends into?
The land is changing hands all the time.
There's a new guy owning it,
a new guy owning it every period.
So who's endowments do we increase when
we put the dividends of the land to the
sones and dammit, you put it into the
endowment of the guy who owned it first.
So put dividends into
endowments of original owners.
Okay.
So this old person who has
the right to the first apple,
his own endowment of an apple,
and also the right to the first dividend,
but he actually has a right to all
the dividends. So his endowment,
the endowment of Mr Zero. Okay.
It's going to be two, one, one, one,
etc. Because he is his
original apple plus he's got a,
and
he has this endowment of an apple cause
you know everyone when they're old has
an apple.
He's also,
because he's on the land before gotten
the right to this first dividend or the
apple that's too. And because
he's the original owner of land,
he owns all the future dividends
streams of the land. Okay?
So we can freak out about land after
we've stuck the dividends into the right
persons endowment. And now we just
trade as if it's general equilibrium.
We just looked for supply and
demand and the present value prices,
which are p one p two p
three, it's Cetera. Okay.
And because it's symmetric,
we know that this is
going to equal one Pete.
We can always make one of them be a one.
Price can be one.
So the present value prices are
going to look like this. Okay.
And the reason I can make this
simplification is by symmetry. You know,
everything,
every generation is the same.
So it's obvious that I'll be able to
keep repeating the same argument over and
over again. Okay. And so
what do I have to, okay, so,
so remember the land has disappeared here.
Even though this generation is buying
the land and selling the land in Fisher
story,
you don't have to pay attention to that.
This guy bought the land and then
he sold the land so he, you know,
it was a fair trade. So he started,
he'd started without an end without it.
The fact that in between
use the land to save,
you can already do that
in a general equilibrium.
You don't need to think about the land
because the only reason this guy is
buying the land is to use
it for a means of saving,
which is already in fishers equations.
So to solve for equilibrium
is then quite simple.
We just,
in every generation we look at,
and remember I forgot to write
the utility functions. So we have,
you have consumption when young and old
is one half log young plus one half log
old.
Okay.
And so therefore INACA Librium we have
to have that one half times the income of
every generation.
Every generation is going to have
three one young plus one one old.
Now from the point of view
of any generation t the
prices are Pete say too when
young and p three when old.
Now remember any generation
cares only about relative prices.
So I can call them p two or p three or
I can call them one and p because the
ratio is going to be p so much simpler
to think of the prices as one in p.
So the old guy,
okay,
if I'm doing any tea like this
period for the old guy here,
you know that's p four and p three he
cares about p three and p four but he only
cares about the ratio of p
three and p four which is p.
So from his point of view, he might as
well have thought of them as one in p.
So his income is three plus one p and
he's going to spend half his income on
that good.
Which for him as a relative price of p,
the young guys gonna
spend half his income,
which is also three plus one p.
This is the relative price
between t minus one and t.
This is the relative price between
t and t plus one but he's now young.
So his price when young is one and that
has to equal three plus one plus one
equals.
So I wrote it as one plus
three plus one equals five.
Okay.
And we solve that and we found
that key equals 0.55 okay.
So there are any questions
about how we did that.
That's where we ended the last lecture.
Is that clear to everyone? Yes.
Okay.
If I didn't have symmetry,
I would have to say this is,
I would have to write this as in general,
this would be three p t minus
one plus one PT over PT.
And this guy would be three p t plus
one p t plus one divided by P t.
Right. That would be in
general, if I had prices,
the present value prices,
this guy income would be given by that
because he's the old at time t and the
young would be given by that.
Okay. And I'd have to do this
a new equation for every t.
Okay.
Who asked? You asked the question.
Right? So does that make sense? Okay.
But I have to do that for every single t.
So I had an infinite number of prices
and an infinite number of equations.
But then you say right
yourself, well, hmm,
you in all this is if I,
if I replace,
if I take the ratio of PT
over p t minus one to equal p,
okay, then the ratio of these two
prices are the same as this price.
And so I've got, um, you know,
I'll have it one equation and one unknown
variable and that same equation will
get repeated every other generation
because when I go to generation, you know,
s which is another generation,
all that matters is the ratio between
p t minus one in PT and PTT and p t p t
plus one. So if I, if I,
uh, assume every Genera,
if I assume those ratios
are always the same,
I'm going to be repeating the
same equation over and over again.
So I can solve at once.
I can solve an infinite number of times.
It's basically the same equation
written infinitely often.
And so as long as I stick in heat,
these ratios constant,
I'm just doing it over and over again.
So I only have to do at once.
So that's the [inaudible].
So it doesn't have to work out that it's,
you know that it's just because you know,
every generation has the same endowments
and every generation has the same
utility. That's why it's such
a simple thing to solve. Yeah.
Is it regular PE before you raised it?
That becomes the old age consumption
price because we assumed a young age price
one
the p this p is just the ratio between,
this is the,
this is how I got p.
P t
p is p t over p t minus one which
also equals PT plus one over p.
T the ratio of all the
prices is always pee.
Okay. The ratio, but between
time, t and time t plus one,
this good is more valuable than that.
Good.
This good is only worth P P is 0.55
it's only worth 55% of this good.
And then this good here is
only worth 55% of that. Good.
So the symmetry assumption, you know, but,
but the symmetry of the problem suggest
that I could guess that the prices are
going to,
the present value prices are going to
decline by 50 by the same percentage every
period.
So,
okay. So let me, any other questions? I
mean we'll keep going with questions. Yes.
Okay.
Yeah. What is the endowment
of the original old guy?
He's the guy who owns the land.
So what does he have?
He has one apple when he's his endowment,
when he's old,
like everybody else who's old,
he has an apple, you know,
his own tree in his backyard. Uh, it
gives them an apple when he's old. Okay.
Or you know, when he's an old man or
an old woman, he can sort of, you know,
barely scrape together one apple.
Now he also has the land.
The land is his for all time.
So the land is paying an apple every year
forever. So his own apple, when he's,
he, you know, at time one plus
the land's apple is this too.
And the land is produced as an
apple every time in the future.
So that's his endowment. I stuck the
dividends of the land into his endowment.
Yeah,
right. I'm not assuming he
lives forever. He doesn't.
In fact he knows he's
going to die in period one.
He wants to do all this consuming
in period one, but he hasn't.
So that's another subtle thing about this.
You can own endowments that
you know occur after your dad.
You know the, the, the, the, if you
own a tree, the tree is going to be,
the land is going to be producing
stuff long after you're dead.
So when you sell off the land, you're
selling off those future dividends. Okay?
Of course,
you're not going to hold the land if
you don't care about your children,
you're not going to hold the land beyond
the time you live because you want to
just consume as much as you can.
So you're going to sell
off the land and consume,
but you're selling off all of
these future dividends. Okay?
So another thing this model
gives us is a new argument.
Argument for the real interest rate
real are being greater than zero.
So why is it because from this formula,
gosh, I was so clever. Where did I,
Oh, here for the price of the acids,
this counter dividends,
that's going to be one over one plus
r plus one over one plus r squared,
plus one over one plus r cubed,
plus dot, dot, dot. By the way,
that's equal to p plus p squared plus Pq.
Do you notice?
Okay,
so the discounted value of the
dividends is the price of land.
So the price of land of course has to be
finite, you know, because I mean it's,
the old guy owned a thing worth
an infinite amount of money.
He'd sell it and he buy
everything in the world.
So if you're going to have equilibrium,
you know,
there's no plot of land that sells
for 10 you know, for $100 trillion.
The price of every plot of
land to some finite amount.
So if the land is producing, you
know, I think it's sort of realistic.
Land is probably gonna produce forever.
As long as the world last,
if you've got land,
you'll get something out of it.
Someone will always want the land. And
so if it's going to have a finite price,
the whole future dividends have to
be discounted to a finite number.
If you put zero in here
for are you get infinity.
So this presence of land is forcing
the discount rate above zero.
Okay.
So it's another argument the Fisher never
would've thought of him cause he never
thought about infinities
or anything like that.
Another argument for the interest rate.
Real interest rate being positive.
Okay.
Any other questions about this?
So we reduce it to one equation and
I'll put back the p here in just one
unknown.
Okay.
Okay. Equals five. And we solve
it and then get peak was 0.55.
Okay.
And it's a quadratic equation.
So you can all solve a quadratic
equations now in this. Oh,
okay. What else do I want to say? So now
you could analyze all sorts of things.
You could do the same
comparative statics Fisher does.
So we changed the utility
function and made this, you know,
a third instead of a half that
would correspond to doing what?
Making people more,
more what? Impatient. Okay.
And what would you think would happen
to the interest rate? Go Up. Okay.
So in the XL file we're going to do just
that and we're going to see it's going
to go up. Instead, we could, um,
we could do the social security thing
and we could have every young person give
something to the previous old,
which means everybody's endowment goes
from say three to two and one to two.
Okay. So they get more in the future
and lesson early on. So again,
you could resolve for equilibrium and
Fisher saying if we've got worn down in
the future and less than
the present, you're going to
have a higher, um, a higher,
a real interest rates. You've got a
higher real interest rate, you know,
you could make the land more productive
and change this to a two everywhere and
see what happens. Okay, so
in this XL file, I do that.
Maybe I'll come back to that. So we're
going to do those experiments in a second.
Uh, but now I do, I want to do two,
two more things before I end
this. The first is, I want to say,
suppose we had growth in the economy.
So what if you had growth?
Where am I going to add growth over here?
I shouldn't have erased that.
So let's have growth.
Okay,
what happens?
Well, Tobin, you know, Yale's greatest
economist after Irving Fisher,
he said something which was 90% right,
but not 100%, right? He said, you know,
I pointed out to him that I got
these guys at social security.
I worked with them.
And anyway,
these people at Social Security and
the social security administration
calculated who were the
biggest beneficiaries of
social security and was Tobin's
generation, the same generations,
my father. And he said, look,
it's your fault that social
security is such a mess.
You benefited and I'm going to have
to pay for it. And He, you know,
just like you're feeling, you're
going to have to pay for it. Um,
so it's even worse for you.
But even my generation's not
getting a very good deal.
Yours is getting a terrible deal to opens,
got a great deal.
And so he said to me,
it's not his fault,
it's my fault because I didn't
have enough children. Okay.
So the question is what happens if
you, you know, what does that mean?
So what Tobin meant is that if instead
of having one child for every adult,
okay, so every family has
two children. In other words,
instead of one fam child for every adult.
So it goes three one, three, one, three,
one we start doubling the size.
You know,
the generations are growing through time.
So since this is 30 years or something,
we can think of the generations doubling.
That wouldn't be such a fast growth rate.
And so Tobin would say, uh, you know,
might've meant if you
double the generations,
you're going to have six and
two is the endowment, you know,
two guys at three and one which means
six and two that you're going to have 12
and four. It's going to
be a gigantic, uh, growth.
And so each generation when it's old,
the young guys only if they're
six and two here now instead of,
so I should use a different color
if I wrote six and two here,
okay,
if I put six and two there,
then each guy would have to,
or two guys at three and one each three,
one guy would only have to
give up half. Uh, we don't,
we have to give up
half of his down at half a unit
because there'd be two of them,
each giving half a unit to the old
guy and each one when he gets old,
getting a full unit.
So this guy would get a full unit.
The next generation would only give up
half of unit because there were four
times as many people
in the next generation.
Each of them would still give a half
making these two old guys get their full
one and when they got old, they'd
similarly get a full one each of them.
So it would seem that if he had a faster
growing population than social security
would be a much better deal because the
young would have to give a bless to the
old and still get fully
paid back when they are old.
And so social security wouldn't
have been a problem. Okay.
So why isn't that a totally,
so why wasn't it our fault?
My fault and your generation,
there's probably not going to have
any more children than my generation.
So what's the, uh, is that
true Tobin's argument?
Is it true that if we just had enough
children we could pay it? You know,
no one would have to lose
out and social security,
we could make the original generation
better off and also every other generation
after that better off.
Yup.
Okay.
Right. Okay. Exactly. And
so you can't know that until
you actually solve a model.
So the point is that if the
generations keep growing like that, um,
the interest rate is going to go up.
And so it's still going to
be a loss because although
you're going to be trading
off minus a half to get one as
opposed to minus one to get one.
So this looks like a much better scenario.
You're going,
once you get to this scenario, there's
going to be a bigger interest rate.
So remember the present value of that
trade is minus one plus one over one plus
r. That's why it's negative
cause ours positive here,
it's minus one minus a half
plus one over one plus R.
Okay. But that's a different are,
that's an are, I'll put it at the top.
That's an annuity economy,
a growing economy.
And that our is going to be a bigger are.
So you're going to,
even though it's minus
a half instead of one,
this thing's going to be small and I'll
see you still ended up losing money.
Okay. But you'd never know
that unless you solved it.
And in fact it's still going to depend
on a little delicate assumption.
So I claim, so Tobin, by the way,
never bothered to work this out.
I claim that
if you're going to be doubling
the population like this,
they're going to be a lot more
people working on the land.
And so the dividends of the land are
probably going to grow at the same rate.
So I would add a two here,
you know,
I'd make the dividends of the land also
double if the population doubled. Okay,
so the land dividends are going to grow.
And so now you can see why the interest
rate has to go up because the present
value of the land still
has to be a finite number.
The present discounted value
of the dividends and the
dividends are growing than
the interest rate had better be growing
even faster if you're going to make that
a finite number. So sure
enough, when you solve it,
you're going to get a higher interest
rate. Okay. And so how would you solve it?
Let's say the growth rate
equals one plus is g.
So one plus g,
you know the growth rate is g and so
every generation has one plus g times
bigger,
the previous generation.
So what would you can just
change this equation very simply.
What would you do?
Well,
for any generation,
it's the same equation except that you've
got one plus g times as many old guys
as you have. Oh, he's a young guys.
The number of young guys is one
plus g times the number of old guys.
So if it's generation tea,
so this will be one plus at time t this
would be one plus g to the t minus one.
And this would get multiplied
by one plus g to the T.
Okay.
And then the dividend five, the the, so
everybody's endowment is also going up.
So would be,
well actually I screwed up.
It would be um,
the old guy one times one plus g to the
t minus one plus the young guys times
one plus g to the t plus the dividend
times one plus g to the t or t minus one,
whichever. Um, okay, so
that's the new equation.
And then he can mult you can
divide through by one plus
g to the t minus one. So,
right. So this is for equate, this is
period teens market clearing equation.
But you see I haven't. Okay. Because
the number of old guys is, you know,
for each one of them's behaving like that.
But they're now this many of them and the
young guys are behaving justice before,
but there are this many of them,
more of them.
And then the endowments of the old
have been grown that for, you know,
the old generation has
this many endowments.
The young has this much endowments when
young and then the land we also assumed
grew.
Okay.
So you can just now divide through by
one plus g to the t minus one and that
goes away.
And that just leaves that Matt goes away
and that goes away and that goes away.
So you'd have that equation all? No. Yes,
he was afraid someone was
going to do that. Okay.
So let's just see where
I got this equation from.
Okay. So I took my original
equation, which didn't have
any one plus cheese in it.
And I just said if I had
growth in the economy,
it's no big deal to
take that into account.
I'm still going to have one
equation so I can still solve it.
It's just that it every time
t how many old guys do I have?
I have each old guy behaving the same
way as before except that now you know
there's been a growth of one plus g.
This is a generation before this one.
So this generation is of size
one plus g to the t minus one.
The young generation,
which is one generation ahead has
grown by a factor of one plus cheese.
So there's one plus g to the t of
these guys. So I take their old demand,
you know,
the same for each guy but different
number of guys and the young generations
demand.
And I have to set it equal to the supply,
but that's just the old guys endowment.
So one for each old guy and at that many
old guys plus the young guys endowment,
same as before. And there are
that many of them. Plus, uh,
the land which I've also assumed
has been doubling one plus j is two.
So the land is also jumbling,
and I'm not sure whether I called this
t or t minus one, but you, you know,
either one, it's not going to
make a big difference. Okay,
so who asks the questions?
Who followed that? Right.
So now I just say I can simple,
I've got one plus g's everywhere
so I can cancel a lot of them out.
That's all I did. So if I divide
by one plus g to the t minus one,
I just get rid of the one plus g
to the tea. Mine is ones I change,
one plus g t to the t divided by
one plus g to the t minus one.
That's just to the first
power I got rid of this one.
I made this to the first power
in this to the first power. Okay?
So I can solve that perfectly easily.
Okay. And I'll do that
in excel in a second. So,
and then we can see what
happens to everybody's utility.
So any questions about what I did here?
Yes.
I know you said it doesn't matter.
Yeah, it's going to change the
answer, but it's going to qualitative.
We'd be the same.
Well it depends whether when I do
this, I want to say this is two, four,
eight 16 or whether I want to
call it one, two, four, eight 16.
So I don't know which is the right thing
to probably, I should have done one, two,
four, eight probably the way I
have it here, which is t minus one.
MMM.
Okay.
Any other questions about this?
Okay,
so the last thing to do is to um,
there's do it numerically cause it's a
pain to have to solve these, uh, you know,
this quadratic things, it's only one
equation but it's still a pain to solve.
And I happen to have written a file
that you can use to solve these all
automatically.
Well this doesn't look too good.
Good.
Okay. So the first one, the first
case I did is I say suppose a,
that's the exponent for how
patient you are. It's half. Okay.
That's the first exponent,
you know, half, half.
So I always can make the log utilities
that two x the two coefficients.
So it's a log.
So I'm assuming utility here you have
young and old is a log young plus be it a
plus one minus say log
old old consumption.
Okay, so a I took to be a half,
that's just what we were figuring out.
I took the endowments when young to be
three and one old to be one in the land
output to be one forever.
And then when you know,
the price is what I'm going to
try and solve for. And so I uh,
you know,
I solve the market clearing equation and
squared it did the XL solver and I got
the consumption, which we figured out
was one, seven, seven, five, one young.
And when old was
3.225 which adds up to the two of them
add up to five together just as we
thought.
And so I even calculated the
utility of each of the people.
I didn't took log utility.
Actually I wrote a monotonic transfers
mation I put why to the a z to the one
minus say it was easier for me to, you
can get positive numbers. That's just a,
that's e to the u. So I might as well
describe utility as the exponent of you.
Take e to it. So it's a positive number.
When you do logs of small numbers,
you get negative. So that's easier
to look at. So that's the utility.
Okay,
now we can do social security.
What happens with social security?
The only effect of social
security remembers the same model.
You just take stuff away from
the young and give it to the old.
So nothing changes except the youngs and
diamond goes down to two and the olds
endowment goes up to two and then the
rest of the model is exactly the same.
And so of course it's going to give
you a different price. PA is different,
so PA is smaller, that means today's
price of next year's good is smaller.
That must be more discounting.
So I did the interest rate one over one,
you know one over one plus r equals p.
So the inverse of p is this thing.
Okay?
So if the Ford way does 161% and if
you think of that as 30 to 30 years,
that's an annualized 3.2% interest rate.
Before it was only a 2%
interest rate annualized, right?
Remember we got the one one
plus R to be 181% 1.81 so are,
is there any 1% okay.
So this social security
doubled the interest rate
from 81% to 161% huge increase
in the interest rate. So social security
has raised the interest rate and so,
you know, you resolve the whole
equilibrium and it had, you know,
not it didn't crush everybody,
but everybody's utility went down
except for the very first generation.
We know they, they,
they won for free. Okay.
But now I could do the same thing
with, uh, with growth. Okay?
I could just solve that
equation on the left.
And so I plug in now the growth rate from
generation to generation plus growth.
And here I've got
mmm.
Two. Okay? So it doubles every period.
Just the example I did. And so I solve it.
And you see that of course when the
generations growing and land is being more
productive and they're more
apples and stuff like that,
there's just more for
everybody to consume.
It's actually made everybody better off.
Okay.
But now we see that Tobin and the
interest rate is higher way higher.
247% instead of 161% okay?
If I do. Now social security
in the growing economy,
every generation one young
only has to give up half a uh,
an apple and get oh, you know,
and get a whole apple when old.
So that raises the interest
rate from 400 from, um,
you know,
247% to 300% annualized from 4% to 4.7%.
Okay? So, uh, it's,
the rate of growth is faster now than
the growth of the economy, right?
This interest rate 247,
300% is faster than the rate of growth,
which is 100%. So again,
everybody is going to lose.
They're going to go from 3.06.
There's still going to lose by
social security to go down to three.
But Tobin would,
I would say is 90% right.
Although more children doesn't solve
the social security problem cause it's
going to continue to, it's going
to increase the rate of interest.
So you're still going to have losers.
Nonetheless.
The loss is now much smaller with
lots of children than it was before.
So Tobin I would say is 90% right.
If only every generation
would have more children,
we still would have had a crisis in
social security. We still would have had,
you know, this, every generation
complaining it was getting a bad deal,
but it would be a lot worse. It would
be a lot less bad than it was before.
Okay. So, um, and then I did this variant,
depending on what we said,
whether the growth was,
whether I had a g to the t or
a g to the t minus one there,
it doesn't really change that
much. Okay. So that's it.
So you see just by a very
simple modification of the
problem you can resolve.
You know, you can just, it's just
the understanding is so much,
at least in my mind, so much clearer
now about what role growth pay plays.
Having more children doesn't make the
problem go away. It makes it better,
but you can never make it
grow away because the interest
rate is always going to
be higher than the rate
of growth of the economy.
Okay,
so let's do one last
experiment on this stuff.
Okay. Another problem to
resolve. So this was a big, uh,
I wrote a paper.
Uh,
the newspapers were saying the same sorts
of things and I'll tell you what they
were saying.
Um,
oh no,
I d mistake.
Sorry.
Okay.
So
remember those pictures that we
showed before of the stock market,
if you discount for it,
if you take out inflation,
the stock market seems to go when these
waves where prices go up and then they
come down and prices go up and they
come down and prices go up and they come
down.
We've had five big waves of stock
market's going up and coming down.
We're now in a period where
they've been coming down, you know,
the stock market is lower now than it was
10 years ago, correcting for inflation,
in fact even not correcting for inflation.
So how,
why would you expect that to happen?
Is there any logic to that?
So here's an old picture of
the stock market. So this,
I wrote this paper in 2005 so remember
at the first class we had a picture like
this. You can see the stock market going
up and down, up and down, up and down,
up and down five waves.
It's now come down further.
This is like 2001 or two. So it's
come down way further than that. Okay,
so is there any explanation
for why that would happen? Um,
so here's an explanation.
I gave a paper,
which a lot of people in the
newspapers were giving. I said,
the baby boomers, I said, you know,
all these baby boomers like me,
we're getting old.
We're going to start selling our stocks.
And so the stock market's going
to go down. And so my account,
so that's what newspapers were saying too.
The difference is that the economists
criticize the newspapers and me and they
say, oh, you're crazy.
They said the stock market,
it can't be that the stock market is
going to go down and everybody knows it's
going to go down because if we knew
it was going to go down in the future,
it would have already gone down now.
And uh,
so okay, so you have to give an argument.
So what I pointed out was that the,
if you look at the history of live birth,
you get the same cycle.
Look at when up and down, up and down.
I don't know if you can lead that.
I can hardly read it myself. What
years are the Pi's? It's so unreadable.
Let's just see if I blow it up a little
bit, whether that, okay, now I can see it.
Okay,
so this is 91020304050 607080902000.
So you can see these are live
births. So birth, you know,
there was a baby boom and then a
plummet and another huge baby. Boom.
That's the famous baby.
Boom, my baby boom.
And then a plummet and then there
was another baby boom, you know,
I forgot what they call it,
the x generation or whatever it is,
some other baby boom that
happened. Basically my baby
boomers, me having lots of,
you know, having children,
another big baby boom.
And then birth rates are going to go down.
So I think that you are the, you know,
the number of 18 year
olds in the country is,
you know at its all high or it's going
to be in two years when my four son tries
to get into college and so there so
and then it's going to go down again.
So this is a cyclical thing that keeps
happening over and over again with baby
booms and busts and everybody knows
about the baby boom after the war.
My generation, the 50s and 60s when I
was born, everybody knows about that,
but they don't realize that there's been
baby boom after baby after baby boom
and this is a cyclical phenomenon.
And then the thing they really don't
know is that it's exactly the same as the
stock market that the stock market
follow those five patterns in the stock
market where the same patterns
of the baby boom. Okay.
So I'm going to end with
that picture. So, um,
okay,
so a picture is worth a thousand words,
but it's not that compelling an argument.
You need a little bit of analytics.
Suppose everybody knew that generations
we're going to get bigger and then
smaller and then bigger and then smaller
with the stock market go up and then
down and then up and then
down as I was saying.
And it's all these newspaper columnists
were saying or would it just stay the
same as these, um, less imaginative,
it kind of condoms, cra credit. You know,
critiquers were saying that it couldn't
have anything to do with demography
because by rationality people would look
forward and they'd anticipated going
down and so they'd all cell before it
went down. So it never go down and, okay,
so that, so it turns out it
does go up and down. Okay.
And that argument the economist gave,
it doesn't make any sense because they
were implicitly assuming that the rate of
interest stayed the same the whole time.
And if the rate of interest
doesn't stay the same,
then there's no reason why the
stock market has to stay the same.
So let's go back to where we were
before and changed the model a little
fit.
So let's suppose that the model
is an alternation between big,
between big generations
and small generations.
So let's suppose that
you have six, two, three,
one and six too.
And I think I kept, that was a good
question. What should I do with land?
I think I kept it at one every period.
Okay.
No, I hope that wasn't the
key to the result. Okay.
So in the paper of course I had,
you know,
people livings 80 years and
I had their income, you know,
reflecting the sort of trend in income
over the lifetime. But I don't really,
for the purposes of this class,
let's say every generation there's a
small generation work goals, you know,
young three old one, then the next
generation, which is just two guys.
So they're both three one guys. So an
aggregate, they're going to be six,
two and the next generations three one
the next generation six to the next
generation is three one and it keeps
alternating like that forever. Okay.
Now how would you solve frack Librium
does the whole thing gets just much
complicated?
I mean what happens after all?
Are there any questions
here about what we're doing?
So it looks way more complicated,
but it's not.
It's a little bit more complicated, but
not much. You can still solve for this.
Okay, so I'm going to not spend
too much time on this because it's,
but I'm just going to show you what you
would do. So what would you do? Well,
by symmetry I claim you can guess that
they're going to be two prices a p.
So you notice that every generation only
cares about the relative price between
one and two young and when it's old.
So there's this relative price,
that relative price between consumption
of time one and time two that's going to
affect the generation born at time one.
It actually has no effect on
any other generation. You know,
these generations are born after that.
So this interest rate,
this relative price between these two
periods affects only one generation.
Okay? So, uh,
this generation is affected
by the interest rate between
time two and time three.
This generation has, is, is
affected by the interest rate.
But time three and time for
every generation is responding
to the interest rates
during its life, not during another
generation's life. So by symmetry,
I think you could guess,
and it turns out to be true that there's
going to be a price relative price,
I should call them small relative price
between for the small generation and a
relative price for the big generation.
Okay. And that the same thing is going
to happen. So this is going to be,
this relative price will be pieced small,
this'll be p big and then we'll get peace
small again here and p big connecting
these guys. And it's just going to keep
repeating itself over and over again.
And by symmetry you, you could guess that
the equilibrium would look like that.
Is this making sense? It's not
making sense. Is it making sense?
So what would I have to check to see that
there's echo Librium will any generate?
So
mmm,
let's do a,
let's do it over here.
Let's do a small generation.
Yeah.
Oh, okay. So we never did the first.
So the first generation, yeah,
it depends on whether we start with a
small one or a big one. But remember,
if we can clear all the markets for
all time except the first market,
that one has to automatically clear.
That's Fisher also.
That was vol Ross's insight. Okay. So we
know that if we can clear all of these,
the first one's going to look very
different, but it's going to clear anyway,
so I don't really have to worry about
it. Um, so we'll see why that works.
Uh,
so what are the generations,
so I'm going to now talk about Martha
clearing it anytime except the first one
just more complicated.
The first one seems really complicated
because there's this guy zero who owns
these dividends that go on forever,
but of course they're just worth the price
of land, which he's going to sell off.
So Ben and we'll come back. Did that
in a second. So in every generation,
every time period,
you're either going to have the
w when small generation is young.
Okay. What do you get? What's the, what's
the market clearing equation going to be?
Well,
the small generation is going to be young,
so that means the old generation has
is big. Sorry. So there's a half year.
So the big old guys, their endowment
is going to be three, sorry,
it's going to be six. There's
two of them. So I can multiply,
I can put the two out here.
Three plus one
P big.
Okay.
Divided by P big.
That's the big old generation plus.
And the young generation,
there's just the old,
they're the usual three plus one p
divided by one.K has to equal.
Now how many endowments do we have?
We've got two old guys plus
each owning one.
So that's two times one.
That's their endowment plus three.
That's the young guys plus the
land dividends. So that's six.
So this should be peace.
Small, not PYP. Small. No,
I don't because the old guys,
the big generation is old.
So small generation is young.
So the young generation,
they're after,
they're consuming in their youth now.
So they're looking at their endowment.
The price when they're young is one,
so they're young. Endowment is
three, they're old endowment there.
Their income is three times the price to
them of one when they're young plus the
endowment of one when they're old times
p small divided by the price when they
were young, which they're
thinking of is one, right?
They only care about the relative price
between young and old and that relative
prices is determined by p small.
So I could call it p t and p t plus one,
but I know that ratio
is going to be p small.
So really it only depends on the ratio.
So I might as well just use
the ratio piece. Small is this,
this is a crucial idea that
I've used a hundred times.
So I think I've used it now, you
know, three or four times. Anyway, so,
but I think some of you don't quite
know what the hell I'm talking about.
So somebody asked me a question,
if they don't know why this is right,
whoever just asked it,
maybe you still don't know why it's right.
Who asked this question a minute ago?
Yes.
Do you understand how I got this? Or
you do okay. But when the old guys,
so the old guys, which is the big
generation, we're, we're clearing time.
We're looking at this time.
So the total endowment is
three for the young generation.
Their endowment is two
and the one unit of land,
that's where I got the total
supply of six. So this generation,
when it's young,
they care about the p small,
the relative price between here and here.
And so they're there,
they're looking at peace, small, the
relative price of one to p small.
The old generation at the same time is
looking over their lifetime at the ratio
of consumption here to here,
which was given by P big.
So they've got a p big here
and they're consuming went old.
So the dividing by P big.
Okay.
But now we've got a second equation,
which is when the,
when a big generation is young,
so why don't you tell me what
that equation is going to be?
How much is the endowment when
the big generation is young?
So that's maybe clearing at this time.
Here are the big generation is young.
So what's the endowment
going to be?
The young, so the old, there's
only gonna be one old guy.
They're going to be too young.
Young guys each have endowment
of three plus one unit of,
so that's eight
and you can see that adds up to
six plus one plus one is eight.
Okay.
Okay. And what's their demand? What's the
demand for the two? So there's the old,
what are the old going to be doing here?
It's in this generation.
We're doing the market clearing.
Somebody knows how to answer this.
Yeah,
over here. The young, the small
generation only has one when it's old.
But big gentleman that's over here,
we're clearing at this time period.
So the a bunch of young guys
and just a few old guys.
So the endowments are six plus one
plus one. The time is going that way.
So that's why that's an
eight over here. One. So one.
Okay,
so this is the one old guys endowment,
two young guys who have three each.
That's endowment of six plus
the land is once you get eight.
That's how I got an eight over there.
That's the supply. So what's the demand?
Who's trying to buy the stuff?
But what's the demand or the old guys?
Yeah,
so and that's going to be what they're
planning to spend when they're old.
Okay, we're doing this one there. So
when the point of they make their plans,
when they young, they anticipate
what the prices are going to be.
And so how much did they plan
to spend when they're old?
Three plus p.
What
over what p
pieces? Small. Exactly.
Over the small plus.
What are the young guys doing?
We're over here.
So two,
there are two of them.
What's this? P what big divided by
almost a half here. Yup. Over what
one. Okay. Exactly. So that's it. So
there are two equations in two unknowns,
p big and p small and two equations.
So to solve this whole model,
you could get two equation.
You could you, you,
you just have to solve these
two simultaneous equations,
which I did. Okay. Now,
okay.
And then you can find the effect.
So all of these old economy,
the economists critiquers would
say, well, P big should equal. Okay,
what,
what will be the price of land by the way?
So what's the price of land
going to be in the end?
What's going to be the price of land
according to Fisher at time? One
at time one,
let's say.
So right here,
what's the price of land?
Remember it's the price after the dividend
is paid. So what's the price of land?
Let's do the present value of the
discounted dividends. What would it be?
Maybe I better write it over here.
Remember the dividends are just
one plus one, you know, one plus.
So there's going to be one
plus one plus one plus one,
but I'm going to be discounting, but I'm
going to be multiplying by something.
So what is the price of land?
P small incidentally equals I could
always write that is one over one plus r
small.
Okay.
I could write p big as
one over one plus r big.
Okay.
So what's the price of land going to be?
Okay,
so it's the price of land starting
here just after the dividend is paid.
So it's very, you know, it's
hard to think about this,
but if you can figure this out then you've
totally understood everything in the
course because this is so much
more kind and uses all the ideas.
I'm just way more complicated way.
Yes.
Well start telling me the formula.
So if I want to multiply four and I do
the first terms, what is this first term?
So you,
you would put one plus our small here?
Yeah.
Okay.
And now what would you put over here?
What
you'd put one plus our big here.
Okay,
very good.
So now you guys really know what's going
on and what would you put over here?
Okay,
exactly.
One plus our small times one plus
r big times one plus r small.
Hey, that's that one. I'm going to stop
with that too. Too much. Okay. plus.dot,
dot. Okay, so you have the
idea now, what's the idea?
Discounting between you're taking the
present value of all the dividends.
So this, this dividend, you have to
discount it by one plus r a small.
This one you have to discount it
twice first to bring it back here.
That's one plus our big.
Then to bring it back here,
that's another one puts our smallest
one plus our big one plus our small,
the third dividend.
You discount first at the small discount,
then at the big discount.
Then at the small discount just like that.
And You keep adding them.
So why should the prices,
what if you look at the
price of land at time two?
Is it the same number?
Is that,
is it the same formula?
Yeah,
it's not the same it.
Well, because at time too,
you're starting here and the
first discount is p big. Okay.
So it's going to be one
over one plus r big plus,
one over one plus r big times,
one plus r small plus one over one plus
r big times one plus r small times one
plus r big plus. Dot, dot, dot.
So this isn't the same as that.
Okay? It would only be the same as
that if our big was equal to our small.
If piece small is equal to p o p big.
So
which one,
which one do you think is a,
the,
which one do you think is bigger?
You think pee small is equal to p big
or one of them is bigger than the other.
And why?
That's the answer to the critics puzzles.
So you see,
you've taken something that
appeared in the newspapers.
It sounds like common sense.
If there are all these young youth,
all these middle aged people like
me bidding up the Pr, you know,
there were so many of us who want to
hold stocks with the peak of our earning
power. We've got tremendous
amounts of money. Um, we wanna,
we wanna, you know, what are we going to
do with it? Except put it into stocks.
You'd think common sense that the
price of stocks would have to go up.
When we get old and we're
selling all our stocks,
you'd think the price of stocks
would have to go down. Okay.
So that would tell you that the
interest rate was going to be
bigger or smaller. So that
would, okay. So that would,
so that would suggest that the price
at time one when they're with a small
generation was young, would be low and
the price at time two would be high. Okay.
And that could happen if this interest
rate was low and this interest rate was
high. Okay, but does that
happen or does that happen?
You can't know until you solve it
in the model. You know the critique,
the critics said all that can't
be right because somehow you know,
the price should even out and everybody
will be looking ahead and buying or
selling at the right time.
You can't buy and sell at the right
time because you're going to be dead.
So you don't have much choice except
when you're young here to save.
And when you're old here to dis save. So
you know, they, they seem not to have,
I've overlooked that small
problem. So anyway. Um, okay,
so the point is that to know the answer,
you can't just reasoned it out verbally.
You have to write down a model,
solve for the model and see what happens.
And sure enough it happens. Like, okay.
So we'll go back to the paper now.
Well,
okay.
Okay.
There are any questions about this.
MMM.
Okay. So all I did in this spreadsheet
is I wrote down those two equations.
So you see that I've got the um,
young and the old or have the
same half half log utilities,
the small generations,
three one,
the big generation is six to land is
always producing one every period.
And we get two different prices.
The PA, the, the price is called Pa,
that's the age generation, which is the
small generation and the beat generation,
which is the big generation.
So you can see that PA is a very small
number when the generation of small,
and that means the
discount rate is very high.
So a high interest rate
when the generation is small
and a low interest rate
when the generations are big. So
when the, when the, when the, uh,
in the moneymaking peak
of the big generation, the
real interest rate is small.
And so that means you're
not discounting very much.
And so the prices are high of land.
And so sure enough,
the price when the small
generation is young is 1.29.
And when the big generation is young,
it's a 2.08 vastly higher.
So it really is the case that as
the generations rise and fall,
the interest rates rise and fall and
the price of land rises and falls and
everybody's rational anticipating
everything. Okay. So,
so there really is, you know, it really
could be, I'm not saying it's true,
you know, cause it could be a coincidence
that these things all matched up.
But the fact is demography can have a big
effect on economic equilibrium and the
stock market. And you can be an
economist and believe in demography.
You don't have to be a
Marxist or something to think
demography and fertility
and all that stuff.
It's going to affect the economy and
for a long time economic strike to wall
itself off from other
social sciences and say, oh,
those fertility people and you know,
all those touchy feely people,
it's got nothing to do with
the wheel markets. Well,
if it has a lot to do with the real
markets. Okay, so one last thing.
Would you rather be in the small
generation of the big generation?
Of course the answer is there,
but tell me why.
Yup.
Okay. That's correct. So I'm
screwed. And so why is that?
Okay.
Well, it turned out to be
the utility of the, um,
okay.
This is the utility of the big generation
per person. You know, of course,
adding the two people together,
it's bigger.
So per person was this a lot less than
the generation of the s the utility of
the small.
So why did that happen?
Why exactly is that happening?
Okay,
so remember, I'm distinguishing sort
of your peak. I'm calling young,
your peak earning years and old.
I'm calling the stuff when you're
retired and not earning very much.
So why is it that a high
interest rate is good?
Yes.
Well,
I think the,
the point is if you're making money
when you're young and you've got a high
interest rate,
that means a high return so you,
you can make a big
return through your life.
Whereas my generation had a very
low return, you know, the money,
the return I'm getting now is
terrible. It's negative. So, you know,
just hideous. But when, you know,
when my parents were young,
they were making an astronomical return.
Incredible rates of return. Okay. So,
and they were earning money, you know,
in their younger years and,
and investing it to save when they were
old and they're getting incredibly high
return.
There's nothing to do with my money.
There are so many people like me
pouring money into the stock market,
we're getting a very bad return.
And that's why it's not so good to be
part of a big generation. So other people,
it said the same thing.
They said,
big generations have to
squeeze into the same houses.
So there be less housing stock,
you know, or we build more houses.
The next generation along through all
these houses built for them and they're
less of them to, you know, so they
get better houses and you know,
everything's better when
you're the small generation,
you're screwed as the big generation.
And here's an example of it. Okay?
So that's it for social security.
All the things I wanted to say
about social security. Now the exam,
as I say, we'll end with a, you know,
you won't have to do the two generations
and all that stuff on the exam,
but the first part about solving for
the 0.55 that one you might have to do
something like that. But anyway,
the lesson that you know,
you can have a controversy in the
newspapers with arguments on both sides.
You never can figure out the right
answer to you write down a model.
And a lot of that can be very simple.
The kind of thing you could
do as an undergraduate.
That's the lesson I'm trying
to communicate. All right,
so from now on though,
we have to change gears and I think the
course gets a lot more interesting. Okay.
But we needed all this background
basics to have the logic of finance.
But finance is really nothing
without uncertainty. You know,
if you don't know what's
going to happen tomorrow,
that's when the thing gets interesting.
That's when you have to think harder.
That's when people make mistakes. That's
when a hedge fund can make a profit.
That's when,
you know,
everything gets more exciting when
there's uncertainty and we have to start
adding uncertainty to are
thinking about the world.
So since they only have a few minutes,
I'm going to spend the last few minutes
just reminding you of what you're
supposed to know about uncertainty.
MMM.
Which is this slide.
Okay.
So it's not a very complicated thing.
Where's the IC PowerPoint? Okay. So,
so there are two kinds of uncertainty,
one of which we're never going to get to.
So the uncertainty that we're going to
work with in this course is everybody
understands what could possibly happen.
So this was a brilliant, uh, you know,
states of the world model
it's called. So, uh,
live nets is supposed to sees as states
of the world right there live next was
the one who first, uh, invented the
idea of states of the world. He said,
we live in the best of
all possible worlds.
So if you don't know what's
going to happen in the future,
we're going to represent that as
many potential states of the world.
Now there are other ways you could model
uncertainty and philosophies. A big,
you know, a big subject and
epistemology and philosophy.
I'm going to stay hew closely to
the states of the world thing.
So if there's something about
the world we don't know tomorrow,
I'm not going to assume that it's
just vague in our minds and you know,
we can't quite make it out. I'm going
assume you actually can make it out.
It's just you don't know which of the
possibilities are going to happen.
So it's many states in the world.
So a uh,
example of that of course is
spinning a dice or spinning to dice.
So you don't know, you know, which of
36 possibilities is going to happen.
Each of those would be
one state of the world.
Okay?
Okay. So we can, um, you know, so
those are all the possible sums.
So they're more states of the
world and there are outcomes.
Notice that you can get to
through 12 is the sum of the dice,
but there's still 36
possible states of the world.
And so that random variable,
the sum of the two dice is expressed as
a function that says in every state of
the world, what is the random variables
value? So our state of the world,
by that I mean something
that's so detailed that it
tells you the value of every
random variable. So that's how I'm
going to be thinking of uncertainty,
that we're here today and a bunch of
different things could happen tomorrow.
And this is an exhaustive list of
everything that can happen tomorrow.
We're going to have to come
back and criticize this
assumption, but it, you know,
introduces uncertainty in a way which is
still quantifiable and not vague. Okay?
So you can talk about the histogram
of outcomes of the dice. You know,
how many ways, what chances are the
chances of getting a seven, you know,
six out of 36 et cetera.
So this is stuff I'm sure you all know.
Okay. Um, the most
famous histogram in, uh,
in all of mathematics is
the normal distribution,
which I don't have time to explain.
And so a normal distribution or
memorize this exponential thing, the,
the dice example, you know, is a
sort of, looks like it. In fact,
if you had enough,
you know,
you had enough dice and you
kept averaging their outcome,
it wouldn't be normally distributed.
So lots of things turn out to be normal.
One of the properties of normal is
that the tail gets small very quickly.
Okay. And so, um, you're not
going to get very many outliers.
The normal distribution is
a very common distribution.
There are lots of reasons why it
should occur all the time. And so it,
and it's also mathematically
very easy to work with.
And so economists for a long time assumed
everything was normally distributed.
But an implication,
as I say,
of normal distribution is that it's very
unlikely something extreme is going to
happen because this thing goes
down exponentially fast to zero.
So you're almost never going to
see something way out here yet.
We get these crashes fairly
frequently. If ever, you know,
10 20 or 30 years or something.
There's some gigantic outlier.
So clearly things can't be normally
distributed and that's called fat tails.
Okay. The, and I'm sure you've
heard about that and the newspaper,
we're going to come back to that.
Okay.
Now there are a couple
things that you need to, uh,
no. So you can, you can
represent the payoff of any
random variable as a picture,
you know, in every state
what its, its payoff. Okay.
So a riskless random variable riskless
investment will pay the same amount in
every state. So I still have a
few minutes here. Okay. Um, okay,
so now two incredibly important concepts,
which I'm sure you know, but I'm,
or at least the mean, you know,
just the average. What's the,
what's the expected payoff?
So the expected payoff is you multiply
the outcome and every state by the
probability of the state
and you add it up. Okay,
so there how many different ways?
Uh, so if you have one dice,
okay, you can figure out
the expectation of one dice.
It's equally likely to get one,
two, three, four, five or six.
And so if you add all those up, multiplied
by six, you get three and a half.
So the expectation of one
dice is three and a half.
The expectation of to die is therefore,
okay,
so, so that's okay. That's one dice, okay.
Now the expectation of adding two dice
together and of course going to be seven
because the expectation of one dice is
three and a half and the other guy says
three and a half in there. And so
the expectation of the psalm is the,
some of the expectations. So it's
seven. Okay? So you know that. Now,
one more thing that you have
to know is the variance.
So how do you measure how uncertain
you are about what's going to happen?
Well, the simplest number to do,
like with the dice is to say, okay,
the expectation is three and a half.
When we don't get three and a half,
we're going to, it means there was some
error. Expectation wasn't confirmed.
So you could just measure the air as the
distance between three and a half and
what you actually got.
So if you've got a four you could
say you are off by a half the room,
but it con but people don't do that.
They they'd measure the
square of the distance. Okay.
And they take the average square of the
distance that's called the variance.
Okay. So it would be, if you've got four,
when you're expecting three and a half,
the error is a half squared.
So it's a,
you take a six times a half squared plus
the six times one and a half squared
plus a six times two and a half squared.
That's where the high
mistakes and the low mistakes,
you'd take a half times a half squared
plus a half times one and a half squared
plus a half times two and a half squared.
Now,
why do they use the expected squared
error instead of just the expected error?
Well, for this simple reason,
she may not have thought of.
If you had to guess,
if you,
if you look at as the error as the penalty
for making a wrong guess and you were
forced at the beginning to say what
guests would you like to make for how the
dice is going to turn out, how the dye is
going to turn out. And if you're wrong,
w will penalize you by this
measure of error. Well,
if you're just taking the absolute error,
your best guess would be any
number between three and four.
You could say three and a half.
He could also say three and a quarter
because if you said three and a quarter
you'd meet,
you'd become closer on all the low rolls
of the dice and be a little further off
on all the high roles and you'd
get exactly the same error.
So you could say any number
between three and four.
But if you make the s the error
of the square of the mistake,
your best guess is always
to say the expectation.
Three and a half is the only is the,
is the,
is the only thing you can say to minimize
your expected penalty if the penalty
is the squared error. So
because of that, um, so that,
that's connected to a
mathematical thing and you know,
in orthogonal vectors and
all that because of that, uh,
the error we talk about
always is the squared error.
And so that's whenever
we're measuring uncertainty,
we're going to talk about
the square to error,
the average of the squared errors
of the square root of that,
which is called the standard deviation.
Okay.
I've one more minute to just finish this.
So this is, I'm assuming you all, uh,
no that okay. Or can learn that. Okay. One
more thing. I'm going to assume, you know,
the last thing is the covariance.
What does it mean to say that random
variables x and y move in the same
direction?
So this was quite a brilliant thought.
So what it means is that to move in the
same direction means if x surprises you
by being above what you would
have expected. So if the
expectation of x as x bar,
and the expectation of y is y bar,
if you multiply the two and they're
both higher than you expected,
you'll get a positive number.
If they're both lower than expected,
you'll also get a positive number.
So by taking this some,
the expected deviation from
the expectation multiplied,
you get a number,
which when it's very positive,
it means they're either both positive
together, both negative together.
So they're going in the same direction.
If one of them is above the average
while the other one's below the average,
then you'll get a negative numbers.
So big covariance means they
move in the same direction,
big negative covariance they move means
they move in the negative direction.
Okay? So I'm going to take it
for granted, you know, vis,
and we're going to take this up
starting right after the exam,
which was on Tuesday.